this talk is called inspector web and
the mystery of the shadow Dom we're
gonna talk about web components and the
underlying shadow Dom that makes them
work so hello everyone I'm Angelina you
can follow me on twitter at angelina
magnum and i work at a company in
vancouver called steam clock software
has anybody else here from vancouver
whoa yeah okay so like two people and we
do mobile apps written in both java
scripts and objective-c and very often
both and before that I worked on web
development for years and I started on
Angel Fire when I was like 12 my first
website had gratuitous use of the blink
tag and animated dolphins everywhere and
I thought it was pretty much the coolest
thing ever and I still think this stuff
is the coolest stuff ever so let's talk
a little bit about how we currently do
things how do we currently build
websites and web applications well
probably either you know you the
developer or someone you're working for
has an idea for some features and you
have a spec and then you start thinking
about okay well what am I going to do to
code these features and make things that
people can interact with and a really
common pattern is that people will say
okay I need a date picker and they'll go
find a UI component library like jQuery
and you'll probably do something like
this so you have some script tag where
you insert jQuery and then you insert
maybe plug-in that's some more
third-party code written by somebody
else and then still yet you need to
select an element and probably tell it
to behave how you want it to hold on a
sec here let me see if I can there we go
that's better and then after you do that
maybe you have more than one widget in
your page and you have some base styles
for your widget for all your widgets on
your page and then maybe you want the
container or maybe you want the contents
of each of those widgets to behave
slightly differently to those base
styles so you end up writing a lot of
really specific CSS I mean who's seen
this before right you write some widget
Styles and then as your application
grows and you need more and more
specific selectors you end up writing a
lot more CSS to really get in there and
be specific and I mean the way we're
doing things now is kind of okay I mean
it does a job right we're still building
web applications
successfully and we're all still
employed as developers and that's okay
but we end up with things like namespace
and selector collisions the more
complexity we introduce in our
applications and sometimes you know by
doing all of this code injection and
manipulation there are elements you
might not expect when iterating over
your Dom I mean when you have a small
application that's really easy to say
okay I know all the things that are
going into this page and I can sort of
have a mental model so that I don't [ __ ]
[ __ ] up but when you have more than one
developer working on this on these sorts
of things and the complexity of your
project grows that becomes harder and
harder to do so yeah those widgets can
sometimes interfere with one another
which is kind of kind of frustrating so
we can do better but we need something
and what we need is encapsulation and
what I'm talking about today with shadow
Dom a web components provides some
really much to meet much needed
encapsulation for front-end development
which I've been kind of wanting for a
long time so I discovered shadow Dom
because I'd read some article and
someone mentioned it and I thought
shadow Dom well that sounds pretty cool
I had no idea what it was and then it
turned out that it happened to solve
this encapsulation thing and I got
really excited because that's really
cool and so the idea here is how do we
create a boundary between the code
recreate and the code that consumes it
iframes were up until now really the
only way to do this and if you're at
Remy's talked earlier you kind of
learned that iframes are you can do a
lot of cool stuff with them but they're
kind of evil and inserting more frames
into your page can really slow it down
so we need another way to do this so
let's let's do a little bit of
investigating since we're all inspectors
let's open up the web inspector here can
everybody see that should I make a
bigger I can make a bigger a few so what
I have here is just a Creative Commons
videos an early animated film and if we
inspect this go into the DOM
there we are we can see that this video
element is largely just a black box
right I mean like we have some
attributes on here like the source
attribute and we can't see the inside of
it but if I go over to the COG here and
I go into my experimental section here
by the way in order for these these
demos to work you need to be running
Chrome Canary and I'll talk a little bit
about the state of implementation at the
end of the talk but we're gonna go in
there and click show Sado dom and then
we're gonna refresh the page and then we
go look at our video element again hey
what's this who's this guy I've got this
shadow root in here and if we expand
that there was a bunch of markup in
there that we couldn't see before so
you've actually encountered Shadow Dom
elements before and you didn't even know
it these are present in a lot of
existing elements like the input range
video element and the audio element and
you can actually see in here that a
spoiler for later is that you can have
nested shadow Dom's too so it's actually
a range element in there for the slider
inside of the video element so the gist
of shadow Dom like what's what's
actually going on here right the best
way to think about this is that shadow
Dom is basically a tiny document that
lives inside of a host element and when
that tiny document lives inside of a
host element maybe it's a div in this
case in our example it's the video
element that Dom is encapsulated and
invisible to the parent Dom unless you
otherwise somehow break that boundary
and so yeah browsers already used them
and now developers can too so let's
create minimal shadow I have this div
here I've just put a border on it so you
guys can see it but if we go into my
markup here we can see that it's just a
div with the idea of spooky right now it
doesn't have any children or anything
and it's just an empty div let's go into
console and let's select spooky
okay so we've got spooky and then let's
do some voodoo with spooky let's give it
a its own shadow root and we passed the
argument of spooky because that's the
element that we're giving the shadow
root 2 and then we insert a shadow root
into spooky but that's not very exciting
because we don't have anything inside
that shadow Dom yet so let's give that
some innerhtml let's say we do the
classic hello world well let's say hello
yes come for you
huzzah it appears ok that's not for
exciting right great that's just it
seems really similar to how we're
already doing things just injecting code
into the Dom but what's really cool
about this is you guys can see that it
says hello Jay has come for you if we go
into the source and we look for our dev
spooky and let me zoom this in here you
can see that spooky is still empty and
but that's really strange right because
we're seeing this text there and I you
just saw me insert this shadow Dom so
why doesn't it exist in spooky and I'm
going to tell you so how this works oh
that's kind of cut off don't know what
happened there nope okay well let's just
keep going so how this works is the
shadow root is inserted into the host
node and when that happens the rendering
of the shadow Dom replaces the rendering
of the children of the host nodes so the
original nodes in the source aren't
altered at all you just replace the
rendering of them and so I mean that's
all well and good I mean the example we
used here is that you know I just
inserted some some h1 tag into an empty
element but what happens if these
elements already
have children right I mean we may not
necessarily want to totally wipe out the
content that's there and so we have a
zoom oh hey did I zoom out on that's
what happened excellent excellent thank
you
all right so we have a special tag
called the Content tag that will specify
the insertion point for the child
elements of the host element into our
shadow Dom tree so for example we've got
the Content tag there and I also wanted
to mention that there is a shadow tag
that will allow you to nest other shadow
roots so let's try it
okay so I've got an unordered list here
and the ID is you with children because
we have this some div with the unordered
list element and what would I call that
spooky with children okay so we've got
our element selected and then we create
another shadow root and we've inserted a
shadow root so that disappeared because
we've replaced the rendering of the
children of that div with our shadow
element which is of course now empty all
right so what do we want to do with this
one let's say
let's say we insert a title insert like
an h2 before that for that list element
and then we want to throw in our content
tag and we don't actually need to put
anything in here the browser knows that
when it encounters that content tag that
we just insert the child elements from
the host element so there we go so now
we have a title and we have the list
here and if we go back into our source
and we look for our let's we don't
search by title with children it's all
tiny again but you can see here that
that h1 is nowhere to be found the only
thing that is there is the host or the
host elements children so that's all
well and good now that this is inserting
a shadow Dom imperatively
using JavaScript but there's also these
cool new magic words that we have coming
for web components called
these tags template and elements so if
you're a designer and you're watching
this talk then you might encounter these
more than you know developer operating
on the might and the relationship
between template and elements and shadow
Dom this imperative JavaScript and why
you should care is anytime an element
this custom element includes a template
tag we're going to do that together in a
moment that in search of shadow Dom into
into the host element so this is a way
to insert shadow Dom declaratively so
there's this template tag and when we
specify a template it's basically a nert
markup used later by its pal element as
I'm going to show you and the contents
are parsed by the browser but not
rendered until they are inserted using
the custom element and so here's just an
example use case that you might want to
use this for creating a comment template
and this one I love because it's
affectionately called the element
element which is just kind of weird but
that's what it's called and in fact in
the end the polyfill I use for the demos
and stuff it's it's called like HTML
element element which is kind of verbose
so element element and these are custom
Dom elements defined by you you can
create modular reusable components using
this so it's time for a little bit of a
story so a common case that I see with
web developers maybe they work at a
consulting shop and some big firm hires
them and says okay until we know we have
this giant codebase that we don't
necessarily want to throw away but we
kind of want to redo our front end a
little bit restyle things but you know
you can't change what's under the hood
in a terrible amount and so I'm like
well that's kind of dumb right like
maybe their markup is really really
awful and you're forced to work with it
and this is something that I've seen a
lot actually I've been stuck in the
situation and other developers I know in
Vancouver have to deal with this they
complain about it all the time and so
maybe you have some crappy L or some
crappy markup like this let's inspect
this one so we have another ul here and
we have some classes on here these
aren't organized particularly well right
I mean like these are some news stories
and we've got a bunch of list elements
some of them have the class applied to
them of breaking and maybe what's been
asked of us is that okay Angelina what I
need you to do is I need you to go and
take that list and it's going to make
more sense for our users if we sort out
the breaking news stories and their own
list and everything else in another list
and so that's what we're going to do
with a custom HTML element so let's pop
over to sublime text here so a few
things that make this work we're gonna
write a custom element over in this news
component HTML thing here the very
bottom here I have some JavaScript
included this script here is written by
Dimitri glazkov who is the author of the
shadow Dom spec and this polyfill makes
it so that we can actually make custom
elements because this stuff is all
really
really bleeding edge so it's not quite
there in the browser yet very
experimental and then the other thing I
want to show you if I go all the way
back up to the top here and where is it
much like including our style sheets
I've done something very similar here
I've included this component and I've
given a link to this HTML document for
my news component and so you can see
that templates for your components are
included in a very similar way very
similar pattern to JavaScript and CSS
already so you're kind of familiar with
how to do that stuff so if we go over to
News component HTML what I've got here
is basically an empty HTML document no
surprises and we're gonna do a custom
element so the first thing we need of
course is this element tag and inside of
that element tag we're going to want to
give it a template and we need to tell
the browser a little bit of information
about our custom element so let's give
it a name let's call it news because
that's what it is and we're going to be
telling that that unordered list element
to behave like our new element but maybe
we want to keep some of the properties
and functionality and and stuff that we
have sort of already from our unordered
list and we can do that by extending so
we just do extends and we're extending
the unordered list element okay oh thank
you I am that would have been
embarrassing hey okay so and then let's
so let's create a div and we will give
this the class of exciting stories
perhaps and we'll make another div for
everything else
and we want an unordered list and to
remember earlier I was showing you that
content tag so we're gonna do that same
thing here and then for everything else
we're gonna put our breaking stories up
there I'm gonna put the rest of them
here too oh but wait I already use my
content tag right so how does the
browser know which elements to put in in
each div and each unordered list right
because we've got two content tags we
need some way to differentiate between
them and let me just put my unordered
list here sorry I'm keeping a lot of
stuff in my working memory so if I miss
something you're totally welcome to
correct me that's totally cool in fact I
would even appreciate it so oh maybe we
maybe we give it maybe we give it a
title to will like it was a title here
that says breaking stories it's gonna be
awesome so we have this special
attribute for the content tag called the
Select attribute which actually I find a
little bit confusing because it with
HTML and CSS and JavaScript we've used
this select keyword kind of in a lot of
places so I don't really know about this
one but so what we're gonna do is we're
going to select from the child nodes of
the host element by CSS selector which
of those child elements appear here so
we're going to put some the braking
elements and then we don't need to do
anything for this one the browser will
know that if these child elements do not
have the braking class applied we're
just going to dump the rest of them into
that content tag okay so we save that
and there's still one more thing that we
need to do in our index.html so right
now we've just got this normal unordered
list these things aren't separate at all
and you know maybe maybe what do we want
to do here maybe just to show they are
broken up we might want to add some
styles but let's just see how this looks
first so let's go into our markup and I
didn't put an ID on that okay
there we are breaking and so the last
thing we need to do in order to make
this all work we've included this
polyfill which you know ideally I mean
it's gonna go away and hopefully soon
and we've included our component in in
our header what we need to do is tell
this unordered list how to behave and
that so we are putting a custom element
in here or that it is a custom element
and we do that with an attribute that is
called he is attribute and we're gonna
say that this unordered list is news so
if we save that and we refresh blammo
okay so what we've done here is we've
remixed this content right so we took
this really crappy markup that we were
kind of probably stuck with maybe is
some big enterprise website and we're
will to remix this in a way that's more
hopefully more usable for our users that
are looking for news stories and we've
got this title in here and then here's
our breaking stories and the rest of
them there and of course again if we go
into the source and we look at where the
breaking unordered list is the only
thing that's there is this unordered
list with you know that is attribute
applied and news and so then a just
remix is that content I shouldn't have
clicked on that so so that's pretty cool
we can remix this existing content so
some interesting points about this
boundary is having conversations with
people about CSS selectors and
specificity any CSS that is applied from
the like the parent Dom and its style
sheets will not affect the shadow
elements but it will affect the elements
that have been inserted from the host
node into the content element so that's
an important thing to note and for those
shadow elements if you do want these
styles from your parent document to
apply to the shadow children
specifically you can do this apply
author Styles attribute on the template
element or imperative lis in JavaScript
you can do route apply author Styles
equals true and then
suddenly I noticed in the explainer the
components explainer that's out there by
the way if you're following along and
you've decided like I'm gonna find out
what Angelina's talking about and if
she's making up this [ __ ] and you go and
you look at the web components spec I
mean that's that's all good but kind of
terse go look for the web components
explainer it's it's it's actually a
really good document to take a look at
there's this reset style inheritance and
if you set that it's sort of uber
enforces that absolutely no user agent
Styles will be applied to your shadow
elements so perhaps you're in a
situation where you maybe you're a
designer and you're inserting some
markup using this shadow stuff that's
just purely presentational markup right
like that's a perfect case here because
this stuff isn't built invisible to the
parent DOM and so it's not gonna affect
the semantic content of your web page at
all and you can do this reset style
inheritance and this is sort of in my
mind this is this is like the future for
like the quickest CSS reset ever because
it will take off the user agent styles
and set everything hmm
so some ideas like what some stuff that
we could use this for right like I
talked about how we can remix existing
content I mean that's great but that's
not going to be with not really
pertinent to everybody's situation but
using the is selector and creating these
modular components will allow us to
rapidly prototype websites by telling
elements what they is it's not a grammar
mistake I do that on purpose to be
clever and so imagine a world where we
have like this library of elements and
you say to your designer okay I need
like a date picker widget in there and I
need you to do something like those news
stories you can tell various elements
what they are and then they'll behave in
a certain way and you can do it really
quickly because you've got all these pre
composed templates another idea I had I
originally gave this talk to a company
in Vancouver that does mobile websites
and we had the idea that we could use
this to serve up alter alternate
navigation control for a mobile website
so anybody that's done mobile websites
know know that if we've got like some
big horizontal navigation in our header
maybe as the size of the browser
collapses slowly we turn that horizontal
navigation into a drop-down drop-down
menu or something like that so perhaps
we could combine media queries and this
technology and then we could create you
know remix the content and create better
navigation patterns for mobile websites
and then overall because we're creating
like these encapsulated components it's
easier to mix and match frameworks and
components because they're not going to
interfere with one another so no longer
do you really need to be like okay I'm
gonna tie myself into this one component
framework and then you know everybody
else stay out just you know cuz you make
some people a little bit nervous so this
stuff is all really cool and all but can
we actually use it right you heard me
say earlier that I'm using Chrome Canary
and I have this experimental flag turned
on and I've got some polyfill and all
the people that want to bring home stuff
to do in production you're like okay
we're gonna walk out now and I mean yes
so can you use it for experiments yes
can use it in production no right now we
have creation of shadow roots in Chrome
Canary only to my knowledge and you want
to use Dimitri glazkov polyfill
available on github for a component
support like element and just for things
like the video tag and the audio tag
this is just a little a niceness when I
was making this talk I compiled all the
WebKit prefix tiles I could find for
people that want to start styling the
native elements like video audio input
range because I realized that there
actually wasn't a big list of them so I
have this gist here you guys can check
out and it's it's not super detail it's
basically just a list of all the ones I
could find and hopefully you guys will
experiment and tell me what works what
doesn't and hopefully by using these
prefix tiles and talking about it we can
encourage other browser vendors to you
know do this and then we can push it
forward and also Jeff Rufus from Mozilla
tweeted this to me today he was posting
in the and the queue for Mozilla saying
like hey shadow DOM is actually a thing
and trying to encourage some Mozilla
supports so that brings me some
important stuff wrapping up and I mean
so shadow dom and web components they
offer encapsulation and modularity for
your front-end code which is a very good
thing and definitely needed but use this
stuff and talk about it and make stuff
with it and play with it because browser
devs do notice and they do care what you
think because you are the people that
are making applications for what they've
made right so yeah that's pretty much
all I wanted to say I want to introduce
you to how these things work and the
next talk by Divya is going to be sort
of building on these ideas talking about
web components
CSS regions and putting those together
so the slides will be posted soon you
can follow me on twitter or email me so
go be brave they make wonderful things
and tell me what you learned about web
components
probably yes
is the is attribute something that I can
set and reset at any time and have it
change like can I just decide to
suddenly change the display of something
this was actually a question I had when
I did my my beta of this talk in
Vancouver and to be honest with you my
answer then as it is now is I actually
don't know we actually tried it live in
the browser and no that did not work but
actually that's something that I
actually might want to mention to the
browser devs because that's I think
absolutely crucial that's really
important I want that too shadow Dom do
you know is that CSS reused for each
shadow Dom Moore's WebKit allocating
some new memory each time I'm not sure
how the memory use works to be honest
with you that is not something that was
in the scope of this talk but um yeah so
I don't know about that one sorry what
he's talking about we were we were
talking about what our companies do my
company makes an app that's coming up
called party monster and it's a joke
because in this app that's for DJing
parties we have a refused to play
Nickelback mode which is sort of our
throwback from Vancouver to apologize
for a Nickelback
but but no there's maybe you could make
your own sort of browser remix somehow I
think that's probably the last question
or just taking another one oh one more
okay cool oh I have a question if you
generate a shadow Dom with JavaScript
and you lose the reference to your
variable where you used to create it do
you have actually a way to get access
again yes come talk to me afterwards
there are ways so I mean here's the
thing about the shadow Dom it's not a
totally totally black box hey spoiler
again you should see it as a corruptible
boundary but only when you the developer
choose to corrupt that boundary and
there are some JavaScript functions that
can traverse that boundary and access
elements in the shadow Dom much like
when you go into iframes and do stuff in
iframes
if you were in Remy sharp stock awesome
thank you very much